and now morisy hamers one effectively to Mason
Appleton long look out front of the goal poked
Away by Wedgewood so now Samberg nine block
shots against Nashville Marksman centers at to
shame from tight quarters was denied on the play
to jump up on the offense when the opportunity
shows itself Smith the former longtime Predator
directs that on goal knocked away there by Helu
split last year with hints toward the blue line
again left side feed march with this time cruising
to the dot side of the net jamming at it was hints
stopped by hellu brenon Dylan the former star is
able to bounce that one all the way down the ice
lung pist Tyler s in finding du shaine gives it
back shot blocked by peon it comes back to list
he'll te it up Bally just about over theine shoots
it PUK got to the spot he had to and made the sa
Cho at it and it's batted out of the air by Wyatt
Johnson Puck turned over B there's a quick shot
and hellu makes the save in their identity so I
think that's just so important where he says if
I were to become the the head coach on any team
any time this is how we would play so not a whole
lot of adjustments that has to make rebound off
the hellu save grabbed by aalo it's a and a fine
pass up ahead Cole Peretti takes the feed Peretti
in all along to the backand wedw got a piece of
it and it went up and out of play Oh effective
on the wing and nice job look at thetic conf he
knows that Peretti is going to take off early
Peretti recognizes okay we're clearly going to
get Puck possession so rather than wait he's
gone there's that sentiment the Brendan Dylan
the pass for NE Rider makes sure he is on side
shoots it and it's reeled in by Wedgewood drawing
an offensive zone face up Lowry Scoops it neita
Rider this Line's been good off the rush lately
drop pass morresy ason Appleton shoots it and
it gets through to the goal Wedgewood one shot
that time for Winnipeg now Appleton with speed
hoping for a return he gets it Mak an appeton
shot kicked Away by Wedgewood and after now is
appon along with Adam Lowry two fights against
Nashville such a strong game on Thursday to the
captain he has the puck being pushed by henan
gets it back to app Dylan around the base of
the boards pavelski at the hashbar tip play the
Jets get it Aon that's left now for Dy with the
drive B save rebound Lowry sweeps it on goal and
it trickles to Wedgewood to be careful he gets it
back from Appleton and out it goes with a little
bit of speed over the line now Tyler San fires it
left shoulder saved by huk on the back hand clear
by pan eers to the mess the coffin back here they
come Nikolai eers cross siid peret he shoots it
kick Sav by Wedgewood who's been sharp here in the
early going his pass into the equip of Lindell
intercepted there by La laeton finding Nino NE
Rider with a wrist shot Wedgewood calmly played
that reeled it back in lobs that right in front
of Kevin between the benches Schmidt knocked it
down now SE and a really good shift the last time
around played it off the Stick of RoR huk for
the time speaking of schi the Jets are going
to try and turn this back Stars caught off ICE
Mark shley on the right shoots it and Wedgwood
no rebound will come through for henan lays it
off the back hand hits two on one short hand of
racing back shley that shot right on goal and
heluk thought about keeping him moving s again
wrapped up momentarily now sud they get on the
move the fine skating to Shan somehow kept it in
Suter cross ice Robertson sherff bangle shot and
hellu reached back maintains his composure keeps
it out they're still alive with it and Harley
scores Thomas Harley with his third goal of the
year and the Stars strike first the Jets think
they're on offense right there and it's duchaine
on his knees that is able to keep that puck alive
just barely on side so now there's aat coming the
other way and this automatically puts the Jets in
the scramble they chase the game you can see how
all Five Guys collapse but there's way too much
time in high ice at D line of time unable to do
so pretty neat moves though Nikolai heers coming
in the Jets in a partial change he'll turn and
send it toward the net never a bad idea Frozen by
Wedgewood stars are in a two two they're almost in
a box formation in the offensive zone and they
stay synchronized back that way all the way to
their own pill Johnston took it from Peretti and
shoots and scores what a solo effort by Wyatt
Johnston a short-handed goal two nothing starts
twom man for check from the penalty kill right
there the back pressure enough to jar the puck
loose and now you've got options because you've
got two guys up on the front line an excellent job
from the 20-year-old his fifth of the season is
his first short-handed goal of the season and
that's just excellent work he lives with Joel
pelski eluk alerts his teammates penal almost over
driving his hits with a shot eluk stopped it l
Sprints cross ice to get a substitute dad enjoying
this one two nothing though Dallas two goals here
in Period two Harley is telling her last peace
dance Chen who carry through Center by domestic
off against four stars wi Zer shoots a t the
front rebound and Peretti shoots and [Applause]
scores young guy with a shorty for Dallas and you
got a great response from another young guy look
at the navigation through the neutral zone it's
Nestico holds the puck holds the puck and then
you can count four Dallas Stars wrapped all around
him and just a great job eers knows when to shoot
it shooting for a rebound or Peretti arrives on
picture perfect there's a shot by morisy and it
really seems that all lines over the last few
games have been strong off the rush did intend
to go in the power play Robertson a lethal shooter
hinan fires stop rebound and H bang that one just
wide open at the backside is duain at the point
this is list Sean side of the goal and the donov
looking to center it perhaps unable to do so
Stars patient with the puck Theon off behind
the goal Johnson in tight Center feed they score
great pass from Johnson to desan and it's 3 to
one Dallas and that is a power play goal they've
just had three goals on the power play the entire
season and this is just again changing the point
of attack look at the confusion that they create
because they go from half wall behind the net
whoop you come right back out the same side
that you think you're going around faine pointed
right at Johnston after he put it in the goal
recogniz ing that fine play as Lindell keeps it in
sends it through off the Stick of huk he made the
save heer's trying to grab that buck and that
shot clubbed down there by heluk he fought it
off looked a little sharper that time here's the
trailer D donov out front of the net and stopped
by n rider he blocked that shot Nita ryer to the
corner for Fox now he put it behind the net all
the way around for Miro hinan shoots and Hell
saw it squeezed it off the boards at hits lell
I follow off balance might take a good bounce for
Mark shley in front Kyle Conor and he had nowhere
to go as W would made the save finding different
ways to get the puck in through the slot area
against a team that doesn't give it up very easily
a nice little pass on the back hand early on that
rush and now Dallas Connor head mans it nice
dick handling by Mark shley as per usual long
shot Brendon Dylan has done it again and
it's a one goal [Music] [Applause] game
he's got four goals what a great job entering
the Zona stop up from shley look at the net
front presence I'm not sure if I gets a tip
on that nobody cares as long as it goes up on
the board a shot that's going right for the
crossbar Wedgewood doesn't get eyes on it CU
a great job Baron to catch up to it Morgan
Barett chips it off the boards Baron thees
off theide by Windwood oh what a chance to
tie the game short-handed does a great job
look at this look from our crew it's right off
the toll lry needs some help shely is there H
can and put it to the corner pass back toward
the line cut off by morisy and that late second
shot stopped as conter drove it toward the net
and the Stars hang on to beat the Jets 3 to2